dream kardashian walks for the first  time on social media dreaming dreaming  dreaming  [Music]  blac Chyna and Rob Kardashian's daughter  turns one on Friday and over the weekend  she took a few of her first steps  dreams proud mama captured the sweet  milestone and posted it to snapchat  dreaming  go go go  the adorable taught almost made it to  the chicken nugget before hitting the  floor china's five-year-old son King  Cairo was also on hand enjoying Sunday  breakfast with his little sis go dream  go dream country go dream rule it's been  an exciting couple of weeks for the 11  month old who celebrated her first  Halloween with three costumes Raggedy  Ann a skeleton and a crab  [Music]